time loop games are not a new genre
while not as common as others there have
been some recent releases within it the
two that come to mind are the recently
released 12 minutes or the critically
acclaimed outer wilds but i found myself
not really enjoying these games too much
otter wilds i personally just couldn't
get into but 12 minutes i found boring
as it's more a puzzle game with a time
loop mechanic added to it it felt as if
i wasn't being awarded for my creativity
when i discovered something new but
death loop is different and it's also
incredible and the reason for that is
the studio behind it arcane studios is
very well known in the gaming space
releasing games like dishonored and prey
while i personally haven't played prey
myself both games are very similar lots
of people see arcane as the game
developer that makes unique narratives
with consequences or moral conundrums
and while that's true i've always seen
as some of the best developers in the
industry when it comes to player choice
just like dishonored allows the player
to take numerous different routes to
complete their objective death loop is
the exact same for those who aren't
caught up to speed death loop's main
objective is killing the seven leaders
of the island in one day except there
are only four opportunities to do so
you're also given four areas to travel
to and once you travel to one area
you're basically advancing the clock as
you only have the morning noon afternoon
and night to kill all seven once the
night is over if you return to the
bunker and all seven aren't dead you
return back to the beginning of the day
so it's not just one objective of
killing a general or sneaking into a
building then leaving to continue with
your next quest it's memorizing the
layout of the map and understanding the
best possible way to complete your
objective with the equipment you have if
dishonored was the rough draft for how
creative arcane can be with their level
design dishonored is their final edit
dishonored showed the gaming community
how level design can greatly impact the
player's enjoyment by combining this
with the basic mechanics of death loop
you get a game with a mysterious story
that ends up becoming a sandbox for the
player to enjoy even after the
conclusion of the game and today i'd
like to talk a bit more about that so
let's get started uh so quick editing
side note despite the amount of praise
i'm about to give the game the game is
performing quite terribly on pc and i'm
not the only one experiencing the
constant crashes or stuttering you're
seeing on screen i've tried my hardest
to cut them out of the video but i do
apologize in advance if they show up i
would definitely say wait for these
stability fixes to be fixed then
definitely consider buying this game so
the biggest issue with these types of
games is the fact that you could lose
all your progress because of one mistake
i personally don't like when my time is
wasted and death loop doesn't take it to
the extreme as you would expect i
believe this was intended to be a
quality of life mechanic but throughout
the game you'll uncover clues weapons
passcodes trinkets slabs and so many
other different things you may have
actually forgotten what you're even
doing the game understands that not
everyone has a large enough notebook to
keep all this written down so arcane
allows you to retain your progress every
piece of info you receive is catalogued
into either a discovery arsenal lead or
visionary lead it's also tracked by the
cycles it's a part of too so you don't
need to spend an entire loop trying to
get info on a lead that doesn't go
anywhere as for your weapons eventually
you'll be introduced to infusions you
can infuse weapons and abilities with
residium and you can keep them
throughout every loop going forward even
if you swap abilities like i had an
infused ability that allowed me to link
enemies together but i swapped for this
game's version of blink and once the
loop reset not only was i given the
original ability back but all the
upgrades that stayed with it while it
may seem questionable to remove such an
integral part of the time loop mechanic
arkhan understands how boring this would
get constantly going back to get your
gear instead of focusing on the plot in
front of you so they let you keep your
knowledge and your gun so you spend less
time building your arsenal back to what
it was you can focus on your own
creativity which makes it much more
engaging and fun to play and it's those
abilities and weapons coupled with the
intricate level design that also make
the experience unique across all players
let me double back real quick and
explain the basics of the game so you
don't get too confused going forward
essentially the protagonist is a man
named cult who is just trying to break
the loop and as i said the objective is
to kill all seven leaders in one night
you aren't expected to do this
immediately so when you get clues those
lead to even more clues and will
eventually tell you where the leader is
going to be at all times what the game
doesn't tell you though is how to defeat
them that part is up to you whether you
plan on stopping the loop or just
killing them to practice the game will
never tell you how in some instances it
may give you hints like playing a
specific dance track will make alexis
reveal his position but that doesn't
kill him you actually have to get the
jump on him which is easier said than
done a good introduction to this would
be your first encounter with harriet she
delivers a sermon in the morning at
carl's bay this is the only time she
appears on the map this eases the player
into less complex alternatives as you
don't need to understand everything just
this one map at this one time so you can
practice this again and again if you
choose to originally you'll start by
getting a feel for the area taking 10 to
20 minutes just looking around and
remembering enemy positions or points of
interest then spending even more time
deciding how to approach the
assassination on my first attempt i
wanted to take the stairs maybe find a
way to sneak around i was really
confused how to get through this area
without being seen as there's at least a
dozen guards in this one hanger
eventually i found a code for a security
door which leads me right into the
hangar without being noticed after
hiding for quite a while i found a
broken staircase and since i had a
double jump ability i was able to get up
there no problem it was a little less
than ideal as i was discovered almost
immediately and had to fend off a ton of
guards on my next attempt however i
discovered a crank that leads to the
other side this was again not as great
as while i killed her i alerted everyone
in the building and we killed each other
this changed on my next run through with
her this is around the time i got
introduced to slabs which is the name of
death loop's abilities if you play
dishonored then you'll feel right at
home as both blink and domino both make
an appearance in this game in this
instance i chose the slab's ether and
nexus nexus functions like domino if an
enemy is tethered to another whatever
happens to one will happen to the other
and ether allows me to go invisible for
a short time i use both of these to
carry out my assassination and i felt
that it was so clean and effective that
i continued to use it even when i tried
to break the loop at the end i used that
same staircase again from the first
playthrough but instead of being caught
i had ether to protect me this time and
then i used nexus to link harriet to
another random enemy and killed them
both i wasn't caught or seen the entire
time and that brought my original run of
around 30 minutes down to 3 but this
isn't all of it of course as ether and
nexus aren't the only abilities in the
game and this nail gun isn't the only
weapon either if you want to go even
further than this every ability has
upgrades to change your play style
whether that change is drastic or not
like with ether i don't waste my power
meter if i'm standing still and at one
point in time as we'll get to later this
was a lifesaver even having a different
gun or a different ability will change
the entire loop and to convey this let's
look at another leader named charlie
charlie for the longest time was the one
leader i could not kill effectively i
found myself always getting into
firefights with him whereas with harriet
i was in and out in three minutes and
one major contributor to this was
two-bit two-bit is an ai made by charlie
who is one of two people besides you who
remember the previous loops the other
being juliana and we'll get to her
shortly none of the leaders or these
eternalist enemies remember it which is
why they always follow the same path
every loop to kill charlie we need to
meet him in up damn at noon he isn't
available throughout the entire day so
you only have a few chances to kill him
on my first loop i had very little
equipment i was able to hold my own but
i'd wish i'd been better prepared after
sneaking around i found a window that
allowed me to enter the building and
this building is a giant playroom
charlie has a fascination with creating
games so he built an entire building
dedicated to a game he calls containment
detachment the game isn't important but
it's more the layout in this large
building with multiple rocky paths on
the sides and multiple floors inside the
building but it's also covered with tons
of guards the first loop like with
harriet was learning the basics i
climbed through a window and eventually
got into a fire fight with charlie a few
loops later i came back because i needed
more information on him but remember i
said that 2-bit remembers all the other
loops as upon approaching the window he
closed it he knew my previous strategy
and forced me to adapt every other
leader once i got into a groove i could
kill them the same way every time
sneaking in through the ducks climb the
stairs link everyone in the room and
sneak out without anyone knowing it's
actually recommended that to outsmart
him you change your gear constantly like
using different guns or abilities
because of this though i had to find a
new way inside this is when i discovered
a small window which is connected to the
room charlie is located in i thought
this was a perfect time for a grenade
and while it didn't kill him it opened
me up to another idea down the path to
charlie's playroom is an elevated
walkway as i walked over i noticed that
charlie's room could be seen from here
so i immediately rushed back to the
bunker skipped time to the middle of the
night so i could grab igor's sniper
after retrieving the sniper i returned
back at noon and attempted to put my
idea to the test after looking around it
didn't seem like i was in a position to
even shoot him and i figured that he
probably wouldn't die either since he
has way more health than many of the
other npcs in the game i'll admit i felt
a little defeated as he was the one
leader i couldn't kill creatively or
quickly at all so i was determined to
figure something out i thought maybe a
change of abilities could help this
charlie when killed drops the shift slab
which is essentially blink from
dishonored every time a leader is killed
they will drop their respective slabs
and even upgrades to the same slab so i
ran through a couple times killing him
and making sure i got the shift slab and
anything i needed to start devising more
plans whenever charlie is alerted he'll
scream and run into his room and when
you confront him in the room he runs
back into the main building i actually
had him tricked at one point in an
earlier loop by hacking the turrets in
his room to kill him which is what
sparked this idea the problem is that i
hacked him when he was already inside i
wanted him to walk into his room and be
blasted right away he is a lot smarter
than i thought and is incredibly
paranoid and protective of his things he
seems to be the type of person that
notices when something of his was moved
because every time whether it was the
turrets or trip mines the moment he
notices something's wrong he bolts so
this plane was an entire bust i decided
to revisit the window again but now with
blink i might be able to do it but the
problem is that there was only one spot
nearby that i could even reach with
blink and even with the upgraded ability
to hover shortly i still could line this
up i had one idea left and if this
didn't work then i was out of options
the windows on the top floor maybe i
could jump off the roof and hover so
that i could be right in line with the
window so that it'd be easier to land on
this would allow me to sneak through the
window and kill him without being
spotted
[Music]
after 45 minutes of trying and failing i
prevailed i was finally able to defeat
charlie without getting caught or
needing to start a firefight to kill him
and it felt great and the fact that i
tried this much as a compliment to the
game's design this is what i've always
appreciated about dishonored because of
how intricate these levels are 9 times
out of 10 if you have an idea or a
different route you could more than
likely do it death loop is the same way
and honestly for a good while it felt
like i was playing dishonored again and
that was a genuinely wonderful feeling
it took all the wonderful elements that
i loved about dishonored and evolved
them in such a way that it was a blast
to play i want to reiterate charlie is
not the only one that is this expansive
just about every leader is engaging to
fight and allows you to come up with
numerous routes and plans to increase
your enjoyment as you go from one
strategy to another for example alexis
is hosting a party with dozens of
eternalists except all of them are
wearing the same wolf mask so you can't
tell where he is just like we have to
come up with new routes and ideas thanks
to 2-bit with alexis we don't have to
worry about that problem but we have
other issues at hand we don't know where
he is as he looks the same as everyone
another example is the leader frank his
area is actually quite easy to navigate
honestly but the biggest caveat is that
his area is only accessible via a class
pass and when you equip the class pass
you lose all of your slabs meaning
repraise is no longer going to revive
you after death so by one mistake you'll
be back at the beach in the morning
because every leader is so unique to
each other and given a location that is
just as unique as themselves with each
of them having different problems for
the player to overcome it makes these
areas so much fun to play every single
time whether it's the first loop or the
tenth and by switching out your normal
equipment with guns and abilities that
are out of your comfort zone it makes
the encounter seem new again like in the
charlie example because my abilities
were changed my way of thinking changed
because now i had different limits than
before i couldn't reach this gap or this
jump without blink so instead of walking
through the front door and scaling the
stairs like normal i was able to take a
different route and while i know the
layout of the map and remember the enemy
placement it still felt different as i
was approaching it from a different
angle it's such wonderful game design
and truly the best part of the game
eventually though you may find yourself
a bit bored maybe you really don't want
to change your play style or you've done
everything that you can think of and it
becomes too easy arcane solves this
problem with juliana while the seven
leaders are the antagonists of the story
juliana is more of the immediate threat
as she can hop into your game when she
wants and completely disrupt the flow of
the loop every now and then she will
appear and not only will she try to hunt
you she'll lock the doors to the bunker
so you have to hack a nearby antenna to
get them unlocked she doesn't have to be
killed to continue but the antenna is a
necessary step she alone will screw up
an entire plan just by existing she's
equipped with the slab masquerade which
to my knowledge is completely unique to
her it allows her to change into any
eternalist she wants and can blend in
with the crowd just by looking at the
two of them it's clear that cole and
juliana are very unique in the way they
dress in a crowd of eternalists they
would stick out like a sore thumb so by
giving her this ability she can make the
player even more nervous and to kick it
up a notch you can even opt to have real
players play her instead of an ai this
ruins the loop even more as now she's
not bound by some script or code they're
a free-thinking player just like you and
they might even know the map better than
you juliana like some of the leaders has
more health than a normal eternalist a
typical enemy can be put down in one
shot to the head with just about any
weapon so if you by chance shoot an
eternalist and they don't die in one hit
it's most likely juliana this is a
pretty easy way to reveal her disguise
but you're doing this at the cost of not
only alerting her but everyone around
you probably the hardest experience i
had in the game with this was when i
encountered fia she's at first dad rock
and is painting this reactor deep in the
building she's not a particularly tough
leader to kill individually but it goes
back to what we said before every leader
has some sort of obstacle and with fia
if you're spotted she'll turn on the
reactor and blow up the entire map even
though i was all the way at the bunker
door which in relation to fia is
literally on the other side of the map i
was killed but not just killed one time
i was reset back to the morning meaning
one fatal mistake can send me back to
the beginning of the loop so already i'm
going into a pretty tough situation i'd
actually failed this a couple times
before and every time juliana was there
now my issues have doubled if juliana
spotted me i'm more than capable of
taking her down but now i have a dozen
eternal lists and fiat to fight at the
same time and i'm on a time limit since
the reactor could blow up at any point
during alexis's party like i said before
my go-to strategy is to use the music
player to single him out of the crowd
but this was during my final loop so i
also had igor and dr wenji here too
there were three visionaries in one
building and to top it off juliana was
also here too and since i was so deep in
the building it wasn't worth leaving the
building to face her one-on-one so my
strategy had to be adapted i needed to
watch every room i was going into since
juliana doesn't act like a normal enemy
and i had to be careful not to get
caught by anyone as not only would i
have every eternalist at the party
gunning for me but three leaders and
juliana at the same time i was
constantly on edge through every
engagement with her but even though my
stress levels were through the roof i
was loving it it was such a tough
experience that i found myself never
taking my eyes off the screen it was
easily the part i was the most engaged
with during my playtime just like 2-bit
changes the flow of the game in his own
way by remembering my past actions
juliana can change the flow of the game
by simply existing giving the player
even more issues to overcome even if
she's not nearby you don't know that
since she could be any one of these
random eternalists you're walking past
and it's not worth giving away my
position just to find her this is just
another layer of death loop's ability to
provide the player with choices giving
them the freedom to make any decision
they want and letting them deal with the
consequences assuming there is any but
this doesn't stop here as i said earlier
juliana can be played by another player
meaning you can be the hunter in someone
else's game it's a wonderful experience
being on the other end of the fight as
now those limits and restrictions change
you're not free to explore the map to
your heart's content not worrying about
the enemies on the map as they're now
your allies the only thing you need to
worry about is cult and since your
restrictions and goals are more relaxed
it gives you more freedom and choice on
how you want to proceed it actually
makes your playtime with her even more
fun if you played through the game
before since you know what leaders this
player is going up against what the
layout is and what the secret areas are
and you can use your assassination plan
to go around this but not everything is
easy for juliana too as she has her own
progression system the more you play and
more importantly the more you win the
more equipment you have in your arsenal
i wanted to play juliana as a stalker
being able to pick off colt from a long
range without even being seen but since
i was limited in weapons i couldn't do
that just yet so i had to make do with
what i had probably the biggest issue is
that you can't respawn yet colt has all
his revives with him so you have to kill
him a max of three times before you can
actually win which is already tough on
its own this just like everything we've
discussed so far makes the game fresh
again as you have a new role on the map
and a new objective with all new
abilities and restrictions which allows
you to be more creative in some ways it
kind of reminded me of assassin's creed
multiplayer back in the day which i did
make a video on if you want to say that
for yourself ac's multiplayer was all
about hiding in plain sight or using
your abilities to counter their
strategies and it felt the exact same
way juliana was such a blast to play and
while some people may have issues with
this mode at the moment i'm having a ton
of fun
death loop is a bizarre game to me i
never expected this game to be this fun
and engaging yes the game does have some
issues but like i said in the beginning
i highly recommend you wait till these
stability and performance issues are
fixed then consider buying the game
death loop won't take up hundreds of
hours of your time if you want the story
that's more around 10 to 12 hours but to
me it's the same as dishonored
dishonored isn't a game that you play
one time then never come back to it's
about repeating the same missions over
and over again which is why they both
allow you to keep your equipment and
continue playing and give you the
opportunity to earn all the equipment
and abilities in the game because they
want to cut out all those boring and
time-wasting mechanics the game has so
you can get back to killing arcane
really wants you to experience the game
after the story is finished those 45
minutes i spent finding ways to kill
charlie that's what they want you to
focus on planing new routes uncovering
more secrets and even repeating the same
route but faster all of it is the true
gameplay loop it's a beautiful game both
mechanically and visually that gives the
player a ton of freedom to plan out
routes and even though some of your
freedom is stripped away thanks to the
obstacles that the leaders have it gives
you more of a reason to think around
that situation not just going in guns
blazing and barely escaping alive but
dealing with the problems at hand and
working your way around them by finding
ways to bend the map to your will like i
said it's a game that gives the player a
ton of freedom to plan out the routes
and the only thing that's stopping them
is their imagination
if you've made it to this part in the
video today then i thank you death loop
was really fun to play but it was also
really fun to talk about i do still
recommend this game and i hope that if
you do play the game yourself you have
just as much fun as i did regardless
thank you for watching today's video as
always like and subscribe if you're new
and if you're a returning viewer i thank
you for coming back i have a playlist of
a ton of video essays just like this if
you want to see more content like this
but as always take care everyone and
goodbye
[Music]
you